corona flickenteppich in deutschland
einige bundesländer erklären deutsche
regionen zu risikogebieten spritztour
stadt quarantäne us-präsident jump zeigt
sich vor dem krankenhaus seinen
anhängern und wird dafür scharf
kritisiert
und überraschung in paris laura
siegemund steht zum ersten mal in ihrer
karriere im viertelfinale eines
grand-slam-turniers
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
schön dass sie dabei sind wie auch
norbert lehmann für den sportverein oder
von mir
wer beruflich oder privat unterwegs ist
muss corona quarantänevorschriften
beachten dass galt bislang vor allem
fürs ausland pünktlich zu den
herbstferien ist aber auch innerdeutsche
reisen kompliziert geworden weil die
bundesländer ganz unterschiedlich mit
den hiesigen problemzonen umgehen
der grenzwert von 50 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner wird derzeit hier
überschritten in remscheid und hamm im
landkreis vechta und in gleich vier
stadtteilen im zentrum berlins in mitte
friedrichshain kreuzberg neukölln und
tempelhof schöneberg
wer aus diesen vier bezirken nach kiel
oder mainz will muss sich auf quarantäne
einstellen wenn er länger als drei tage
da war volker check berichtet sie machen
die nacht zum tag auch an diesem
wochenende in berlin dabei vergessen
viele offenbar alles was sie tagsüber
beherzigen abstand halten mundschutz
tragen
über die situation gerade in der
hauptstadt macht sich auch der
gesundheitsminister öffentlich sorgen
ich kann nicht verstehen dass es in
dieser stadt restaurants gibt in die ich
reingehe der einzige mit mass gewinnen
und wurde dann noch angeguckt wird als
wärst irgendwie vom anderen mond wenn du
eine maske trägt und ihr dann noch
gesagt wir brauchen sie hier nicht
tragen
schleswig holstein und rheinland pfalz
ziehen jetzt neue seiten auf hier müssen
rückkehrer aus inländischen
risikogebieten wie berlin in der regel
zwei wochen in quarantäne
ausnahmen gibt es nur wenn der
notwendige corona test nicht älter als
48 stunden ist der reisende weniger als
72 stunden im risikogebiet war und es
triftige reise gründe gibt wie
sorgerecht und medizinische behandlung
schwierige zeiten auch für hoteliers ii
matthias weber wagner aus mainz er muss
jetzt reisen dem schlimmsten fall
abweisen oder im benachbarten hessen
unterbringen
zum flughafen das ist das nächste
nächste größere einrichtung wo man auch
abends noch einen corona das machen kann
wenn er hat dann nicht wiederkommt wie
ihnen vielleicht in eines unserer
schwesterpartei in frankfurt ein paar
tieren der reichstag oder das
brandenburger tor viele
sehenswürdigkeiten liegen in berlin
mitte und das ist jetzt alles
risikogebiet die zuständige senatorin
wehrt sich dagegen dass einzelne
stadtteile zum risikogebiet erklärt
werden
in den großen städten sehen wir dass
inzidenz sehr stark steigen deswegen
hilft es nicht auf dem finger
aufeinander zu schauen sondern wir
müssen insgesamt lösungen finden um
diese stark steigende infektion wieder
in griff zu bekommen berlin auch heute
voll von touristen viele wollten oder
konnten nicht umbuchen
das problem ist wenn man sich erstmal
china gebucht hat kann die reise nicht
zurückgeben und ich sag mal passieren
kann überall was kann uns auch nicht mit
den öffentlichen medien sehr viel
und ja also versuchen es so gut wie geht
von von anderen menschen fernzuhalten
deutschland bleibt vorerst ein
flickenteppich in sachen inländische
risikogebiete denn die bundesländer
dürfen bei den quarantänevorschriften
eigene regeln festlegen
im bundestag wie gehört ja auch in
berlin-mitte gibt es übrigens ab morgen
eine masken pflicht wo welche regeln
gelten können sie auch bei uns online
nachschauen oder direkt fragen stellen
an unseren rechtsexperten felix
zimmermann ab halb acht im livestream in
der zdf- heute- app immer wieder kommt
es zu grösseren corona ausbrüchen gerade
auch in schlachthöfen in einem fleisch
betrieb im niedersächsischen bösel
wurden inzwischen 81 menschen positiv
getestet dort gelte nun für mindestens
zwei wochen verschärfte maßnahmen wie
ein verbot von mannschaftssport oder
masken pflicht im schulunterricht
insgesamt setzt sich bei den
neuinfektionen der trend der letzten
woche fort im 7 tagesdurchschnitt haben
sich täglich 2180 menschen mit dem virus
neu infiziert gestern lag dieser wert
bei 2140 unsere nachbarländer kämpfen
mit noch viel hören infektionszahlen in
tschechien gilt seit heute wieder der
notstand italien plant eine masken
pflicht auch im freien und in
frankreichs hauptstadt paris gilt ab
morgen wieder die höchste corona
warnstufe bars und sportstätten müssen
schließen für restaurants
einkaufszentren und altenheime gelten
strengere vorschriften im großraum paris
haben sich in den vergangenen sieben
tagen 260 von 100.000 menschen mit dem
corona virus infiziert eine lehre aus
den ersten corona monaten nie wieder
dürften pflegeheime so abgeschottet
werden denn die wochenlange isolation
sei gift für die heimbewohner die
seelischen und körperlichen schäden
seien zu groß davon ist die evangelische
heimstiftung überzeugt sie hat die
erfahrungen von ihren über 140
einrichtungen zusammen getragen
anna basbug details endlich wieder zum
gemeinsamen mittagessen gehen
für michael ist das wichtig wegen kroner
musste der 92-jährige hier im pflegeheim
in winnenden wochenlang allein in seinem
zimmer sein was furchtbar war es sehr
schlimm wäre mit niemanden sprechen
könnte nennt man wohl doch gewohnt dass
man unter den an
wenn ich nie wieder die älteren
einsperren müssen stattdessen tägliche
symptomkontrolle und strenge masken
pflicht für pflegefachkräfte und
besucher im märz hat corona die
pflegeheime überrascht olga ja kuczynski
wusste nicht wie sie sich verhalten
sollen und schutzausrüstung war kaum
vorhanden
inzwischen gibt es klare regeln jeder
neue bewohner wird er kommt ins haus mit
dem testreihen bin jetzt kein negatives
vorliegt dann werden sie installiert und
gewartet bis der test da ist über die
letzten monate hat die evangelische
heimstiftung als größtes
pflegeunternehmen in baden württemberg
verschiedene corona maßnahmen
ausprobiert und angewendet auch wenn
eine zweite welle kommen sollte die
heime noch einmal schließen auf keinen
fall das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
und wir müssen lernen als gesellschaft
wir alle dass alte menschen nicht per se
auf ihre schutzbedürftigkeit reduziert
werden dürfen weil hinter folge sperren
dass sie ein sie die am anfang der
pandemie zu spät in den fokus geraten
sind sagt schneider dürfen nicht
vergessen werden
ich bin trotz alledem noch etwas
selbstständig kann sagen was ich möchte
was ich nicht möchte ich bin da es im
normalfall mensch zumindest für die
nächsten monate haben sie hier in
winnenden erstmal genug schutzausrüstung
auch gruner schnelltest soll es bald
geben sie fühlen sich inzwischen
gewappnet gegen das virus eine andere
brennende frage wie kann pflege
bezahlbar bleiben
gesundheitsminister sparen hat heute
seine vorschläge dazu erläutert er will
pflegebedürftige und ihre angehörigen
finanziell entlasten
halbherzig main verbraucherschützer
schwarz pläne
die gesamtkosten für die betroffenen
würden trotzdem viel zu hoch bleiben
bernd beim team für einen platz im heim
zahlen pflegebedürftige oder deren
angehörige im schnitt 2000 15 euro pro
monat 786 euro davon für die reine
pflege diesen anteil will der
gesundheitsminister jetzt deckeln
was wir wollen ist vor allem auch einen
rahmen setzen der pflege kalkulierbar
macht kalkulierbarer als er heute für
viele dann auch insbesondere in der
stationären pflege ist
spahns reformplan umfasst drei punkte
der eigenanteil für die pflege soll bei
700 euro gedeckelt werden allerdings
maximal für 36 monate tarifverträge in
der branche sollen stärker als bisher
durchgesetzt werden und mehr geld für
die sogenannte verhinderungs und
kurzzeitpflege zu hause der
koalitionspartner spd signalisiert
unterstützung bemängelt aber dass nicht
aus einkommen geachtet wird
weil es natürlich nicht sein kann dass
die verkäuferinnen genauso viel bezahlt
wie der millionär also hier wollen wir
gerechtigkeit und das bedeutet für die
spd dass starke schultern mehr tragen
müssen die reform soll mit steuergeldern
finanziert werden sechs milliarden euro
an kosten nennt minister sparen zu
zaghaft kritisiert die linke
viel zu viel sagt die fdp statt den
jüngeren immer neue lasten aufzubürden
sollte er vielmehr die weichen stellen
für eine nachhaltige und
generationengerechte finanzierung der
pflege
das wird nicht ohne private
zusatzvorsorge gehen es handelt sich
maximal um ein reförmchen
es ist weiterhin so dass die pflege zur
falle für altersarmut wird bislang sind
es nur vorschläge des
gesundheitsministers die auf eine
prüfung warten die zeit für sparens
reform ist knapp keine busse keine
bahnen die gewerkschaften verdi hat zu
weiteren warnstreiks aufgerufen
der öffentliche nahverkehr soll am
donnerstag in nordrhein westfalen und
baden württemberg und am freitag in
bayern schon angekündigt waren
warnstreiks morgen in hessen und
übermorgen in niedersachsen und bremen
verdi verlangt für die rund 87.000
beschäftigten einen bundesweit
einheitlichen tarifvertrag bestürzen
sorge und solidarität mit den juden in
deutschland
das sind die reaktionen nach dem
anschlag vor einer synagoge in hamburg
es ist beschämend wenn ein bürger
jüdischen glaubens in deutschland auf
der straße attackiert wird sagt
regierungssprecher seibert
ein mann hatte gestern einen jüdischen
studenten angegriffen und schwer
verletzt
ermittler stufen die tat als
antisemitischen mordanschlag 1
das verrieten die anteilnahme in hamburg
ist groß am tag nach dem angriff vor der
synagoge vor dem gebetshaus wird
deutlich wie sehr die hansestadt
überrascht wurde von dieser tat die man
im weltoffenen hamburg nicht erwartet
hatte wir lassen uns natürlich jetzt
nicht einschüchtern
es ist natürlich ein schock und ein nein
das der angst und und auch wut darüber
dass so was in hamburg passiert an so
einem also einen tag wo wir jetzt auch
unsere laubhüttenfest feiern und das
laubhüttenfest erinnert jedes jahr an
den auszug der israeliten aus ägypten
und findet wenn möglich draußen statt
die synagoge steht unter polizeischutz
auch deshalb konnte der angreifer
schnell überwältigt werden
der mann zeige psychische
auffälligkeiten so die ermittler
er trug einen tarnanzug und hatte einen
zettel mit hakenkreuz in der tasche mehr
konnte die polizei bislang nicht
ermitteln was wäre in der wohnung aber
nicht gefunden haben sind
rechtsextremistische strukturen oder
dinge die auch tatsächlich strukturen
rechtsextremistischer gewalt hindeuten
ein einzeltäter verwirrt oder nicht die
tat fällt zumindest zeitlich zusammen
mit dem jahrestag des anschlags im
handel
die gefahr hat sich mit sicherheit
vergrößert der antisemitismus tritt
heute viel öffentlicher viel freier auf
als er das noch vor 10 oder 15 jahren
getan hat und es muss ein
gemeinschaftlicher gesellschaftlicher
konsens herbeigeführt werden
und da ist unsere politik gefordert der
zentralrat der juden und die jüdische
gemeinde in hamburg fordern etwa mehr
raum für begegnungen mit schülern und
zwar nicht nur in der grundschule wie
bislang sondern auch deutlich später
wenn vor allem soziale netzwerke eine
größere rolle spielen
us-präsident kann möglicherweise noch
heute zurück ins weiße haus
trotz corona infektion führte aber auch
schon aus dem krankenhaus wahlkampf mit
16 teams innerhalb von 30 minuten
zudem verließ der 74 jährige kurzzeitig
die klinik obwohl er noch ansteckend
sein dürfte aus den usa peter jäger
ein qubit 19 patient geht auf spritztour
vor dem krankenhaus lässt sich donald
trump an seinen wartenden anhängern
vorbeifahren und an der presse winkt in
die kameras fast zeitgleich
veröffentlicht er auf twitter ein vor
aufgezeichnetes video
wir haben eine überraschung vorbereitet
für einige der großartigen patrioten auf
der straße sie stehen schon lange dort
haben trambahnen und lieben unser land
ich sage euch ich mache ein
überraschungsbesuch mir geht es gut will
trump zeigen und mit seinem auftritt die
nachrichten dominieren dabei bringt er
seine eigenen sicherheitskräfte in
gefahr
auch ärzte des krankenhauses sind
entsetzt die idee dass so etwas ohne
entsprechenden medizinischen befund
erlaubt wird ist absurd maske oder keine
maske sie saßen in einem hermetisch
abgeriegelten fahrzeug in dem das
zirkulierende virus menschen in gefahr
brachte
mittlerweile wurden zwölf teilnehmer
einer veranstaltung im rosengarten des
weißen hauses ende september positiv
getestet die meisten gäste ohne
mindestabstand und maske möglicherweise
hat sich schon hier angesteckt auch
seine sprecherin kellie mcelhinney
meldet heute sie sei infiziert noch
gestern hatte sie interviews gegeben
sprach ohne maske mit den reportern
dreimal wurde trumps herausforderer
beiden mittlerweile getestet er ist
negativ bestreitet weitere auftritte der
präsident schießt dagegen aus dem
krankenhaus einem tweet nach dem anderen
raus laut seiner ärzte könnte er bereits
heute entlassen werden
seit fast zehn jahren wird in libyen
gekämpft es ist ein blutiger bürgerkrieg
ein bisschen hoffnung brachte die große
libyen konferenz in berlin im januar
zentrale punkt die waffen
sie sollten schweigen vor allem aber
sollten keine neuen mehr nach libyen
geliefert werden
eine absichtserklärung war das verändert
hat sich so gut wie nichts im
kriegschaos in libyen
und so gab es heute wieder einen gipfel
daniel kommt der flughafen von tripolis
sinnbild für ein kaum mehr
funktionierendes land zentrale akteure
des extrem verworrenen konflikts im
westen der von den vereinten nationen
anerkannten noch regierungschefs hat der
bald abtreten will
im osten generell haffter auch der
verlor nach fehlgeschlagener offensive
auf tripolis an einfluss die
unterstützer aber ägypten die
vereinigten arabischen emirate und
russland wollen ihren einfluss behalten
auf der anderen seite gilt das vor allem
für die türkei so gelangten trotz der
seit april laufenden eu-mission zur
überwachung des waffenembargos weiter
waffen ins land
heute nun wie der konferenzen per video
dabei erneut alle unterstützer diesmal
zudem die nachbarstaaten geleitet vom un
generalsekretär und dem deutschen
außenminister sein fazit es gibt grund
für vorsichtigen optimismus
wir sehen vermehrt zeichen für ein
umdenken von der militärischen hin zu
einer politischen logik und dieser
schließen sie sich immer mehr an
fortschritte habe es jüngst vor allem
bei einer libyschen gesprächen gegeben
zudem gab es ein abflauen der kämpfe
aber die tatsache dass momentan in
libyen nicht gekämpft wird hat sehr
wenig mit internationalen
vermittlungsbemühungen zu tun und fiel
damit dass ausländische
staaten mittlerweile ein
kräftegleichgewicht etabliert haben in
libyen aber diese staaten also
insbesondere russland die vereinigten
arabischen emirate und die türkei
überhaupt nicht auf eine
verhandlungslösung hinarbeiten
ein eingeborener konflikt könnte ihren
einfluss dagegen sichern allerdings auch
die in öl export weiter stark hemmen und
den brauchen aus finanziellen gründen
mittelfristig wohl beide seiten die
woche der nobelpreise hat begonnen als
erstes wurde der für medizin
bekanntgegeben
ausgezeichnet werden die entdecker des
hepatitis c virus hcv otter und charles
reis aus den usa sowie der print bringt
micro haften
die jury erklärte dank der forschung der
virologen sei hepatitis c inzwischen
heilbar
das habe millionen menschenleben
gerettet eine hepatitis c infektion kann
schwere leberschäden verursachen
und jetzt der sport noch den namen laura
siegemund wird man sich merken müssen
allerdings vor wenigen tagen der
überraschende turniersieg bei den us
open im doppel heute die ersten
viertelfinaleinzug bei einem grand slam
turnier im einzel durch den zweisatz
erfolg bei den french open über die
spanierin paul abbott labs an einem
nasskalten oktobertag hat sich laura
siegemund in paris endlich warm gespielt
gegen paul aber durchaus barcelona
hinten im bild kann sie sogar einen 3 5
rückstand im ersten satz in 1 7 zu 5
umwandeln und zeigt dabei das
variantenreiche hre tennis badura die
hier 2015 den titel bei den juniorinnen
gewonnen hat scheint beim letzten
seitenwechsel das ende schon zu ahnen
letztlich souverän mit 7 zu 5 und 6 zu 2
gewinnt die 32 jährige tennis oma laura
siegemund gegen ihre zehn jahre jüngere
spanische gegnerin inzwischen genießen
sich auch am erfolg freuen und dann aber
auch die nötige spannung haben uns noch
weiter zu festigen
um es noch weiter zu bringen müsste die
schwäbin nun im viertelfinale eine
zweimalige wimbledonsiegerin schlagen
die tschechin petra kvitova power woche
für die deutsche
fußballnationalmannschaft drei spielen
in sieben tage heute die ankommt von
joachim löws mannschaft in köln dort
mittwochabend das testspiel gegen die
türkei danach die beiden wichtigen
nations league spiele gegen die ukraine
in kiew am zehnten und dann gegen die
schweiz am 13 oktober dann auch wieder
in köln ganz ganz bitterer abend für
jürgen klopp sein fc liverpool ging
gestern bei aston villa mit 2 7 unter
die höchste niederlage der reds seit
beginn der premier league ratlosigkeit
beim deutschen trainer es gibt so abende
da läuft einfach alles gegen einen schon
in der vierten minute geht aston villa
durch watkins und führung
derselbe spieler erhöht auf 2 0 für den
außenseiter nach dem anschluss von salat
kommt für liverpool auch noch pech dazu
der schuss von mcginn wird unhaltbar
abgefälscht doch damit nicht genug
watkins zum dritten stellt zur pause auf
vier zu eins nach dem wechsel sorgte für
das fünfte villa tor wieder abgefälscht
sie können es selbst kaum glauben denn
nach dem zweiten tor für die reds durch
salat trifft check kritisch zum 62 auch
dieser ball abgefälscht jürgen klopp
muss da schon lachen sie dann noch das 7
zu 2 durch grünlich es gibt ebenso
abende da läuft einfach alles gegen 1
na ja solche abende soll s creed
herbstliche aussichten gleich von katja
honnefer ein tief jagt das nächste es
regnet und die sonne lässt sich nur kurz
zwischendurch blicken
bettina schausten begrüßt sie im heute
journal wie gewohnt um viertel vor zehn
danke für ihr interesse ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und bis
morgen wenn sie auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren tief brigitte
brachte am wochenende kräftige unwetter
auf der alpensüdseite aber auch an der
côte d'azur zum beispiel in nizza oder
auch in ligurien in san remo
jetzt beschäftigt uns das tief brigitte
weiter und wenn so viel bewegung in der
atmosphäre ist dann unterscheiden sich
die nacht und tag temperaturen kaum
morgen liegen die höchstwerte in west
und mitteleuropa um 15 grad und heute
nacht sinken sie auf norderney am
nieder- und am oberrhein bis auf 11 grad
deutlich kühler wird sei am alpenrand
mit 5 grad
der regen von heute abend verlässt uns
bald richtung nordosten aber es kommt
neuer regen heran
von südwesten von frankreich her und er
breitet sich bis zum frühen morgen aus
und erreicht dann etwa das westliche
niedersachsen den thüringer den
oberpfälzer und den bayerischen wald
dieses regenband sieht im laufe des
tages weiter nach nordosten
dahinter geht es noch kräftige schauer
und am nachmittag setzt ein neuer regen
am bodensee und auch im allgäu ein nur
das berchtesgadener land bleibt davon
verschont
dort scheint die sonne genau so wie auch
hier im äußersten osten bei einem böigen
wind die temperaturen steigen auf 11
grad an mosel und saar bis 18 grad an
der elbe und wechselhaft geht es auch
weiter schönen abend noch